listen ralph season one of this series
was a huge
surprise breakout hit season two in my
opinion are
arguably topped it so tell me moving
forward into season three
how much pressure did you feel to
continue
with this great build of this series and
did season three exceed your own
expectations
um good question uh season i mean we
didn't
you know i never felt because the three
writers of the show the creators of the
show
have such a handle on it we have a such
a trust they've built such a trust and
they've earned it
with how they approach the show and how
they
uh pay homage to the source material
and respect that and and and everything
going forward and we built this
beautiful ensemble cast of such terrific
actors um so i was not concerned like
whoa the pressure's on can we
do it again in season three it was more
about continuing it
and for season three i was most excited
about because it
gets to dive into the origins of miyagi
dough
and cobra kai and then open up it sort
of elevates itself
and and broadens the scope of the story
um and for for me personally through the
russo character i get to explore going
to okinawa which i actually got to do
play scenes with tamlin tomita as kumako
and yuji okamoto is
has chosen and they both knock it out of
the park and add such a
heart soul and and everything from the
karate franchise you're looking for and
then information for larusso to grow
from
and then and push forward and then into
our
amazing ending of the season it's uh
it's one of my favorites um my favorite
it's a it's a great season i don't want
we won't give too much away uh william
tell me where do we find johnny
at the start of season three season two
was a very
difficult end to the season for him
where is his head space at and what
would you say his motivations are
at least in the beginning of the season
well season
opening of season three i think he
wished uh he never met miguel
at season one you know i mean he he
tried an experiment he opened up
pandora's box and opened cobra kai and
for a minute he
was finding himself and helping people
and then it ran away from him and then
chris came into the picture and then
cobra kai took a a turn and the and his
student got
injured and his son's responsible and so
johnny feels ultimately all the weight
of that at the
end of uh season two and season three is
a
short time after those events and he's
uh
licking his wounds and um in deep
despair
and he's he's lost his girl carmen and
and any hope and chance of life again
for him is the rugs pulled out from
under him so
um he's he's a broken man um
and uh but through through the season um
you know has a
alignment with daniel in the in their
common interest of
finding robbie and they both feel to
share this responsibility and try to put
things back together
um and also the the heaviness of chris
having taken the dojo was a super
painful experience for johnny the man
that he
that you know that almost choked him out
as a kid and now he lets him back into
his life and earns his trust again and
then betrays him
that way he has a new engine ticking
inside of him and
he wants to make that right so um he's
dormant for when we first see him um but
through a series of events starts to uh
re re-define himself come back and
get his gusto and um and uh
and reconnect of course with uh with
miguel and help him
and continue to be the sensei which
happens in a really cool exchange
actually it's kind of informed with the
rel a scene he has with chris
uh and chris tells him uh you know i'm
always going to be your teacher and uh
that
rings a light in johnny and johnny goes
off and says wait a minute i'm a teacher
too and goes and uh
and that gives him wind in his sails and
then really uh miguel
throwing it back in his face and
challenging him and his own kids barking
it back at him
all those things wake him up again and
he feels a new sense of purpose
i love that i could talk to you forever
about this series it is great
keep doing it and congratulations on
season three people are going to
go crazy for it all right so thanks guys
you